we see that the collection isn't
necessarily a holiday movie in some
sense it work it's a parody to release
it at during the you know when
thanksgiving relatives are coming well
yeah it is a cold weather movie yeah you
wouldn't believe how call the was
shooting this year and i think and you
know i think how it is you look at the
we were really done done ish right
around now last year and you know we
still need to do some like polish on
posts like that but they started looking
at dates and you know Jane where's Burt
was very full with big movies spring
starts the earlier and earlier with like
the big summer type movies and I want
you to summer forget about it you know
and then and then there was our deal all
the slots were taken for every weekend
in in September and october with horror
movies and ones that we were aware of
that we knew like a good we knew
sinister was good and we don't want to
go anywhere near that didn't want to go
anywhere near paranormal for you know
and so it's like well what's a good
weekend we can go and then you know one
of the people FLD was like well what if
we went the weekend after Thanksgiving
which is often a slow weekend because
there's the big things even movies and
so we might have a weekend kind to
ourselves to certain extent and be a
month removed from all horror movies and
then be a month before horn when we
start up again in January so it might be
a good little date to open because you
know scream opened around this time with
the first screen when it came when it
came out and it people try to counter
program all the time Lionsgate and
dimension and often do and it's
sometimes hard to do and so but it
seemed like a good idea and you know it
was cold weather movie and also they had
the whole like um Christmas motif with
like the ba you know we have the box I
don't be seen the campaign there's a
commercial art the one commercial that's
like that done then this holiday season
and then some gifts shay from you so he
can play off the whole Christmas thing
and yeah we're like the black friday the
real black friday you know so you know
it is so worked out
you